hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 89 of game
programming so today we're going to talk
about finishing our little player
animation so we see that if we launch
our game what we have is this dancing
little player guy not cool
let's go into our player class and see
what we need to do to finish our player
guy so what we have is an animated
sprite class that's what we made last
time we also have this awesome sprite
sheet that I made in episode 4 8685 I
don't know but the point is we have
these we have four directions here right
down up left and right let's apply them
into into our game so if we hit up the
animated sprite I think that's the one
that no okay so sprite sheet I think yes
sprite sheet has our different player
sprite sheets our sob sprite cheese
let's copy and paste that three times
for each of the directions play it up
play our left and play right okay so now
we have four different sprite shades for
the directions now we need to work out
which of these numbers are go here so
this 0 0 is the x and y offset okay x
and y offset as we can see over here is
actually in a sprite precision not pixel
precision so food for up which is the
one we'll do now it's offset 11.00 we
need to do is type in one over here for
player up similarly left is offset by
two and right is offset by three from
the beginning in terms of the x axis so
we need to pop in two and three and that
should be that should be totally fine
okay
so now that we've done that if we hop
back into our player class we have these
animated sprites here so let's copy them
paste them a few times here change this
one to down this one to up this one
through left and this one to right and
out of this thing will create play up of
course as a sprite sheet play a left
here and play it down and play a right
sorry here okay and of course the sizes
of this price don't change and the
amount of frames in the animation is
obviously three since we whoops since we
have one two three four each of these
okay awesome
now that's figured out let's apply these
things so we've got test up
we need to make sure that we update the
current one that's selected now there's
so many different ways we could do this
okay I'm just thinking right now there's
really a lot so what I want to do
instead because we don't want to update
all them if they're not used I'll make
another animate a sprite object called
an 'm sprite I don't know let's
capitalize that and we'll set that equal
to null for now okay but when we do
create the player
it's kind of like how we set this Friday
call to sprite or play a forward here
we'll set the annum sprite the animated
sprite equal to download yes to begin
with okay and then I'll set it to this
okay it won't create a copy of it I'll
just set it equal to this okay kind of
like a pointer I guess and then what
we'll do is we'll app that will update
the animated sprite so if we run this
just real quick to see what it looks
like once we fix our error here which is
test like a sprite will set it to an 'm
sprite dog espera let's check that out
okay we don't ask little crash here we
get a null pointer exception for some
reason so what's not at this point and a
sprite we set that equal to down here I
believe down is actually all to a value
I'm not sure why we're getting a null
pointer that so is enema sprite and all
at this point yeah that's why I care
that is No okay let's um-hmm let's let's
do a few things first of all let's
actually move these what if we um mmm
that's quite odd because I'm I know why
that's happening but it shouldn't be
okay let's let's probably drop we could
set this equal to down technically if
let's take a look at that quickly okay
that works cool um let's get rid of it
here so basically what we want to do
here at this point is um we also want to
make sure that obviously when he changes
direction he moves so instead of all
this uh animate whoa okay we've cleaned
up the animation code already that's
great but what we need to do is set the
direction so when we hit the UP button
we've also got the down button here
input dot left and input dot right we'll
set the MMS protocol to a sprite so
let's set input dot up to so let's set
an in sprite equal to our Piper live and
fit down and remove this top here left
and right we'll do the same
so for down I'm Sybil set it down for
left we'll set it to left and for rice
will set it to right okay let's check
that out so if we move yeah of course I
screwed something up there okay left
what is left left is left okay what have
we done here hmm that should be right
that's weird
let's go back to our player so some
reason up and this works that works but
you have to put your left we kind of
screw up here even though we do set
animated sprite equal to left which is
the player that left sheet which which
is set to that one so that should be
right hmm I'm not sure why that's not
working with the high school zone
I wonder if we change this to 1 yeah
that works
huh so what if we changed to 3 so now
that works huh okay that's um why is
that happening I have no idea it's like
I must be no that is playing [ __ ] maybe
I'm referring to a different file I have
no idea okay anyway that seems to work
I'll work that out later okay so now
that that's annoying as well as it
okay so the other thing we need to do is
probably say that um let's go back into
our player there's a few little quirks
that we should fix up such as um these
things so else if we chuck and else here
it will make sure that we can't select
both at one time as well as words down
because we can't set both at one time
and the other thing we need to do is
probably say that if we're going down
and left we should handle that as well
so for example it's just good inertia
that it's setting it I think that if we
go ahead and say and left if well we
could just okay so let's just check that
problem out real quick if we move up and
right for some reason it's um setting
that equal to that okay this I think
hang on that is Oh we've does this thing
matter
oh crap we've got this stuff I thought
we removed this card damn it
great okay I thought this should be an
update anyway let's some comment that
card out quickly
not that that should do anything but um
yeah there we go
that fixed it okay yeah that was weird
that was a quick little bug that we had
there now what we should do is probably
fix this animation stuff up so what we
wanted to do was only play the Indian
animation if we're walking okay and
that's actually really easy to do right
all we have to do over here I'll leave
that card commented out all we have to
do over here in update is if walking we
need to update it otherwise don't update
it now that's not you can see how that
kind of works now what we want what we
might want to do is set the frame equal
to zero as well so in other words
else and sprite dot we can't set the
frame can we okay so we should set frame
to set frame to zero
okay and we'll make that method real
quick so let's create the method so
public will would set frame and index I
guess and all we'll do here is we'll
actually set this sprite equal to sheet
dot get sprites index oops now to handle
this quickly we can say that if index is
greater than XI get sprites dot length
minus one then let's return and let's
also print out an error to the console
so system dot error dot print line index
out of bounds in plus well we could just
say this Conway but we're probably
better if we set and now that's fine
okay cuz I'll give us the exact memory
address of this thing okay cool so
that's just in Casper to the index or
backing player will set frame to zero so
if we're not walking what we should see
is the that frame okay and that's a very
simple way to fix it now our sprite
looks fine animation looks terrible
because I'm not I'm not good at this
kind of stuff but I might fix that up in
my own time and then maybe let it get
back in but that is um that's gonna
pretty much wrap up this episode now
there is one thing that I wanted to show
you guys okay that's the thing that I
told you guys at the beginning of the
last episode if you head over to my
website right now okay what you'll see
is um this okay so this is whe know calm
what you'll see is on the home page
showing away there'll be a next topic
and then they'll be a bunch of options
now I don't know how okay I don't know
how people have already parted there's
15 total votes already okay I don't have
a clue how because I know I did not know
this anyway but the point is this thing
is here for you guys to be able to
choose
what you want me to do next because
we're at the point now we've pretty much
done everything and the stuff that we
need to do next
could be done in any order because the
main engine lays the graphics of the
engine have been laid down so what I'm
giving you guys the choice of is
non-player characters a menu and
inventory system or items so what I mean
by non by mobs essentially is well hey I
kind of thing by menu so basically on
player character so we can have mobs
like roaming around and stuff menu by
menu I mean well what do you think a
menu that's pretty obvious isn't it like
a main menu so you guys can select if
you want to quit if you want to play the
game if you wanted to change level
whatever inventory system like an
inventory system like realm of the mad
God has where you can um drag and drop
items and I guess inventory system
really bills linked with items pretty
well but that's what it's looking so
look it's looking like mobs are winning
right now again this voting hasn't
technically started if you don't but
hang on okay to vote you need to
register an account you might already
have one if you do hit login
but otherwise hit register ok all you
need to input if you hit register is a
lot of google trying to order fuel my
stuff automatically to register all you
need to do is pick a username spaces are
allowed by the way we can username enter
your email address and create a password
and of course do this CAPTCHA thing so
that i'm so that boss don't make
accounts and poet on my polls but yeah
that's all you'll have to do again and
then hit create new account you don't
even have to like confirm your email
address i would make sure that it is
valid because if you do forget your
password you can request another one
over here okay but once you do login
again if you do hit login and you login
what you'll see is if i go back to home
here what you'll see is you can actually
vote ok so me i'm probably going to vote
for items I think items are cool okay
something to hit for and also there's
something on one vote so I just hit for
it and that will actually process that
vote I've seen you can see items in has
two votes any was recorded blah blah
blah
in terms of comments there also if you
want to suggest something you can
actually leave a comment here as well
you can say they've already done that
but other than that guys pick something
here hit the vote button and that's what
we'll probably do next episode now
tomorrow there's not going to be an
episode again programming there's going
to be an F
network chat programming because people
have been blogging me about that for a
while and I do want to finish that
series since it's not an overly big
series but other than that be sure to
vote on this poll because that will
determine what we do next and other than
that guys hit like hit the like button
below this video because remember 200
likes equals one video per day and 300
likes equals two videos per day alright
so I'll see you guys later goodbye
you